[Music]
fame glory riches and acclaim
for those whose dream is to be
recognized in their own lifetime
fundamental physics is not the best
choice of career
over 2000 years ago the greek
philosopher democritus speculated that
mata instead of arising from
combinations of earth air fire and water
was built from tiny indivisible
constituents called atoms
these atoms would be small fundamental
and indestructible and he hypothesized
that such atoms would be the basic
ingredients of all the objects and all
the matter that we see around us
this was called the atomic hypothesis
in time this did turn out to be true but
not until 60 generations after
democritus had died and his own atoms
had been laid to rest within the warm
sun-baked mediterranean soil more
recently in 1783 the english clergyman
scientist john mitchell was thinking
about the implications of newton's laws
of forces when they replied to the
corpuscular theory of light mitchell
thus conceived of bodies which could be
sufficiently dense and massive that the
escape velocity from their surface would
be even greater than the speed of light
itself in this case mitchell theorized
even light would be unable to escape and
these objects would be highly massive
but totally dark
he named them
dark stars
mitchell's idea was clever revolutionary
and correct and so far ahead of its time
that it would be entirely forgotten for
two centuries
atoms as matters building blocks and
black holes as compact astrophysical
objects
two ideas first conceived of centuries
before they were widely acknowledged to
be true
to this we can perhaps add a further
even more revolutionary idea
an idea first suggested by theodore
kaluza in the early 1920s an idea mused
on by einstein himself but still argued
about today
this is the possibility
that there are extra as yet undiscovered
dimensions to space
additional hidden directions beyond up
down and across
x
y
and
directions we have never yet been able
to perceive
but what would this mean
where would such dimensions exist and
what would they look like
and finally how could we
ever
be able
to detect them
[Music]
this video has been kindly sponsored by
babel the number one language learning
app einstein spoke german marie curie
spoke french durac was english
groundbreaking physics is an
international effort and that was only
in 1927. today our world is more
multilingual and global than ever so
being multilingual is hugely helpful yo
vivo and espana empathy aprender espanol
usando babel
it's a simple fun way to learn the
basics and more babel starts you
straight from the beginning with
conversational tools it's focused on
helping you communicate not solve
grammar puzzles its lessons having been
designed by real teachers with real life
experience not algorithms or ai it even
has a podcast section i've personally
found podcasts an amazing way to improve
my spanish and babel has lots of
different fun ways to help you absorb
the language in a natural native way so
click on the link in the description to
get up to 65 percent off your
subscription thanks to babel for
supporting educational content on
youtube
our story starts in 1916 in the midst of
the largest and bloodiest war the world
had ever seen
while the meat grinder of the somme ate
up the youth of europe the thoughts of
albert einstein were on higher and more
eternal matters
for the last 10 years einstein had been
attempting to extend his special theory
of relativity developed in 1905 to
include gravity after many false starts
he finally succeeded and formulated his
general theory of relativity
this turned gravity the force we are all
familiar with into geometry the curved
geometry of four space-time dimensions
it was a beautiful theory but a hard one
to understand
the mathematics was unfamiliar the
physics seemed obscure and any possible
experimental consequences seemed few and
far away
one of the physicists grappling with
this new and remarkable theory of
einstein was theodore kaluza
kaluza had been born into a vanished
society scientia as a part of prussia
under the german imperial kaiser he grew
up in the cultured university city of
koenigsberg where his father was an
academic drinking long and deep from the
intellectual values and traditions of
german-speaking europe and its great
universities the places and society he
grew up in have now utterly vanished or
changed silesia has long since become
part of poland while kernigsberg has
become kaliningrad host port of the
baltic fleet of the russian navy his
ideas however
remain
while thinking about einstein's
equations coluza asked himself a
striking question
according to einstein geometry was
dynamical and central to the physics of
gravity
so what would happen if einstein's
equations were instead written out for
five space-time dimensions four space
dimensions and one time dimension
instead of the conventional three space
dimensions and one time dimension
at first glance this idea seems silly or
at least a topic suitable only for a
mathematician with no interest in the
real world because of course in the
world in which we live there are three
directions or dimensions to space not
two and not four
but three
so while it may be an interesting
academic exercise to think about
einstein's equations in four spatial
dimensions it surely can't be of any
relevance to the actual physical world
that we live in
surely not indeed unless kaluza argued
the extra dimension was so small as to
render it unobservable
in this case the spatial geometry would
consist of three large spatial
dimensions
and one
small one
and so kaluza wrote down einstein's
equations of general relativity for such
a space
and solved them
the result was striking the equations
separated themselves allowed themselves
to be rewritten in a different way and
then they came back together with an
entirely different structure one that
can be read as a purely
three-dimensional set of equations
describing einstein's general relativity
in three dimensions
plus the dynamics and interactions of an
additional force that behaved in a way
very similar to the electromagnetic
force we are familiar with plus
additional particles
kaluza had found something stunning
gravity in four spatial dimensions in a
limit of one invisibly tiny extra
dimension was equivalent to gravity in
three spatial dimensions plus an
electromagnetic force
he published his result in the
proceedings of the prussian academy of
sciences with the paper sponsored by
albert einstein himself
this result was amazing it was deep it
was striking
and almost no one cared
not then and not for decades afterwards
indeed this was a time of destruction in
the depressing world of politics the
rich culture and science of 19th century
germany which had hosted and nurtured
many brilliant jewish scholars from
einstein downwards was being slowly
destroyed and perverted by the ascent of
the cancerous ideology of national
socialism with its doctrines of racial
purity and aryan supremacy in the more
exalted and eternal world of physics
destruction creative and fruitful
destruction was also the order of the
day during the 1920s the new and
radically mysterious world of quantum
mechanics was being discovered the
previous foundations of the subject were
being dissolved and in the whole history
of physics there has been no better time
to be young with time on your hands the
world at your feet and atoms in your
brain
general relativity meanwhile may have
been deep and it may have been important
it was not however as exciting even in
three spatial dimensions general
relativity in the 1920s 1930s or 1940s
had limited contact with observation add
in an unobserved and hypothetical extra
fifth dimension to the mix and why
should anyone spend their time on this
rather than the magical and
revolutionary world of quantum mechanics
then opening up
and so
first for years
and then decades
and then for the better part of a
century
the possibility of extra dimensions was
relegated to the backwaters of science
[Music]
nestling among the colorado rockies is
the mountain town of aspen
an expensive and exclusive home or
second home for those rich enough to
afford a residence among the beautiful
surroundings
but alongside the socially elevated
houses is a centre for physics
where physicists gather to discuss
current projects and deep ideas about
various topical areas
[Music]
in 1984 a conference was being held
two of the physicists attending michael
green of queen mary and westfield
college part of the university of london
and john schwartz of the california
institute of technology were some of the
few keeping the flame alive for extra
dimensions
as thunder rolled outside green and
schwartz worked out and presented their
solution to a problem that was widely
believed to render extra dimensions
physically impossible
and as this green schwarz solution
became widely known
extra dimensions rapidly became one of
the hottest topics in theoretical
physics
but what
had happened
[Music]
for many decades physicists had ignored
the idea of extra dimensions in favor of
other more exciting ideas starting in
the 1970s however one obscure and
oddball idea appeared to require for
consistency the existence of extra
dimensions
this idea
was string theory
string theory has a justified reputation
as a difficult and complex subject its
origins though come from one single
problem take the equations that describe
a one-dimensional object under tension
think of violin string or a cracking
whip promote these equations to a
relativistic limit where the ends move
at the speed of light itself finally
take the quantum mechanical version of
these equations and study them
take strings make them relativistic make
them quantum mechanical and you have the
subject known as string theory
[Music]
when the ideas of string theory were
first developed by the italian physicist
gabrielle veneziano in the revolutionary
summer of 1968 they were thought of as a
possible explanation for the behavior of
the strong force which binds the nuclei
of atoms together despite five years of
intense work from 1968 to 1973 this idea
did not succeed there were two major
problems the particles the theory
predicted did not match those actually
found in experiments on strong
interactions and more abstractly the
theory simply broke
probabilities failed to add up to 1 if
space did not have an additional 6
spatial dimensions beyond the 3 we
already know
this meant that string theory by the
early 1970s seemed destined for the
rubbish bin of failed ideas
but for a small number of physicists
including green and schwartz
something
nagged
many things about the theory worked
surprisingly well there were odd and
unexpected calculations that looked too
good to be simply a coincidence why were
these happening maybe string theory was
actually
something else
maybe using string theory to describe
the strong force was a desperate attempt
to force a square peg into a round hole
maybe just maybe they and others
whispered in hushed voices string theory
was actually the quantum theory of the
gravitational force the long-awaited
theory that underlies everything were
the strings of string theory the
fundamental components of the universe
the response
was disinterest
[Music]
quantum gravity was obscure string
theory was obscure put the two together
and the number of people working on the
topic was literally a handful
for this was the great age of the
standard model and new particles were
being discovered almost every year
string theory in mid to late 1970s
physics was about as fashionable as
powdered wigs and top hats
it also appeared to be facing
insurmountable problems any versions of
string theory that tried to include the
type of particles that make up the
standard model appeared internally
inconsistent
what happened in rainy aspen in 1984
was that green and schwartz found a way
to solve
this problem
the problem was one of what are called
anomalies for a whole host of
calculations in the quantum theory
probabilities were not adding up to one
green and schwartz however discovered a
new previously missed term in the
calculations and with this included all
these previous problems disappeared and
the quantum theory was suddenly
consistent again their result was and is
called the green schwarz anomaly
cancellation and as news of their
results spread
string theory a theory which required
not one not two but six additional
dimensions to space
became one of the most popular subjects
in theoretical physics
it was a pivotal moment and the
thunderous storm outside echoed its
import the physics of extra dimensions a
subject that had previously scraped its
existence on the fringes of
respectability was now the subject of an
intellectual gold rush as physicists
flocked in to try and relate the physics
of string theory and its six extra
dimensions to the more familiar physics
of four dimensions and the standard
model it had been proposed that the
particles and forces of our world were
born out of the different ways in which
these fundamental strings could vibrate
and they needed 10 dimensions to vibrate
within in order to fit our reality
the quest for quantum gravity a theory
of everything that had haunted einstein
on his deathbed was once again the
center of attention
[Music]
i was in san diego with my wife one day
in 1984 looking out at the beautiful
ocean
the phone rang and it was my friends
andrew strominger and gary horowitz they
were excited because string theorists
were building up models of the universe
and needed to know whether calabi
calabial manifolds really existed
i was happy to confirm
that they did
mobius strips
klein bottles
roman surfaces they are complex
mind-boggling difficult to comprehend
but still
geometries
and so it goes with the almost
impossible to visualize extra six
dimensions of string theory
geometry as a subject goes back over 2
000 years pythagoras's theorem euclid's
textbook circles parallel lines infinite
planes it is one of the oldest subjects
in mathematics
and so we can ask what possible shape
could these tiny extra dimensions take
would they be built up from simpler and
more familiar ingredients such as
straight lines circles and ellipses or
might they rather be radically
unfamiliar objects with strange and
unusual topologies
one of the most interesting and most
studied examples of possible geometric
shapes for the six extra dimensions are
what are called calabial manifolds
named after the italian-american
mathematician eugenio kalabi and the
chinese geometer ching tang yao
these spaces had already attracted
interest from mathematicians because of
their beautiful complex geometry complex
here as in complex numbers such as i the
sum of a real and imaginary number
they are not easy to visualize and are
topologically complex a typical calabi
has hundreds and hundreds of the higher
dimensional equivalents of holes
mathematically they are a marvel but why
have these manifolds been studied so
much within physics
why did early string theorists choose
these bizarre geometries to fold up the
extra six dimensions
one reason is that the geometry of these
spaces automatically satisfies the
equations of einstein's theory of
gravity general relativity the equations
of general relativity are restrictions
on the allowed forms for the curvature
of space-time these equations are one of
the deepest and most powerful ideas in
all of physics and so they are expected
to be true not just in the
four-dimensional world that we inhabit
but also within any deeper frameworks
that would extend our known laws
and this includes ideas such as string
theory
these collabial
fit the bill
but that is not all
einstein's equations are classical they
do not include any quantum physics often
there are solutions to classical
equations which are destroyed the moment
quantum effects are turned on the
quantum leads to uncontrolled almost
infinite amounts of extra energy that
act as a wrecking ball on the simple
classical solution that was started to
avoid this wrecking ball classical
solutions and theories of quantum
gravity need something extra a form of
extra protection extra symmetry that
will act as a shield against these
quantum effects
calabial geometries have this extra
protection
it is called
supersymmetry a form of extra symmetry
that is especially good at taming the
most dangerous effects of quantum
physics in brief supersymmetry roughly
ensures the quantum effects split into
two parts both catastrophic both almost
infinite but with opposite sign so that
they precisely and totally cancel each
other out
however supersymmetry is still only a
conjectured symmetry and it may or may
not be part of the true theory of the
world
when physicists started getting
interested in calabiaos in the mid-1980s
only a small number of examples were
known it was dreamed that this small
number might then turn into a
semi-unique path leading from the ten
dimensions of string theory directly to
the standard model
scientists dared to dream
was this about to become one of the
greatest moments in all of physics
not quite
the number of such collaborate spaces
just kept growing and growing
their names sound deliciously exotic the
quintic hypersurface in cp4 or the
mirror quintic
now billions upon billions of such
geometries are known and instead of
being enumerated manually by a lone
mathematician scribbling across sheets
of paper
impersonal silicon spits them out by the
microsecond
and so we are left with an incredibly
complex and elegant theory
but also
a problem
the world in which we live is not at
first glance
ten-dimensional
were these extra dimensions to exist
physicists believe they would be
everywhere in four dimensional space but
extremely small
some estimates putting them at more than
a quadrillion times smaller than an atom
so how could we ever know or prove what
form these extra dimensions actually
take
if they are too small to be observed
and indeed more fundamentally
what does it even mean to talk about
extra dimensions
that we cannot see
[Music]
what does it mean to see something
there is an anecdote about the famous
and charismatic physicist richard
feynman although as with all good
anecdotes it may not be fully true
feynman the story goes was conducting a
phd viva the verbal examination for a
student who had just submitted a thesis
in theoretical physics the student's
thesis was on quantum gravity and he had
undertaken many long and intricate
mathematical calculations
feynman however was concerned that in
the process the student had lost himself
in mathematics and forgotten his physics
feynman started asking questions about
physical scales physical sizes physical
properties
what feynman asked was the wavelength of
visible light
i don't know
said the student
perhaps a meter
feynman got up from the examiner's chair
and walked towards the student
do i
he said in his new york trawl
look blurry to you
[Music]
the reason we can see each other and
recognize the fine structure of each
other's faces is that the wavelength of
visible light is a bit smaller than a
micrometer or a millionth of a meter any
objects much bigger than a micrometer do
not blur when viewed in visible light
and so visible light allows us to
resolve objects down to these lengths
objects smaller than this however cannot
be seen with visible light atoms exist
they are as democritus said part of the
natural world however being 1 000 times
smaller than visible light it is simply
impossible for them to be seen using
visible light it simply lacks the
necessary structure to resolve them
x-rays of course are another matter but
for most of our existence humans did not
have access to controlled sources of
x-rays however even if we cannot see
individual atoms we can still feel their
effects
every time we touch anything with our
hands or sit down on a chair we feel the
effects of atoms the fact that when we
sit down we do not carry on plunging
through the seat of the chair is because
of the summed effect of billions upon
billions upon billions of atoms and the
electric interactions between them when
we sit down the entire earth is pulling
on us downwards using the force of
gravity what resists this pull is an
electric repulsion that occurs as the
matter that is us tries to pass through
the matter that is the chair and this
repulsion originates from the atoms
making up both even though we cannot
directly discern individual atoms
so for atoms we can feel their effects
even if we cannot directly resolve them
what would be the analogue for extra
dimensions
if there is a secret geometry to space
at the very smallest distances what
effects could this have at larger
distances on those unable to resolve the
extra dimensions
to understand this it is worthwhile to
consider what a dimension
is
we are all familiar with three
dimensions these are the directions we
move in the way we label the positions
of objects
there is one dimension of up and down
and two for moving horizontally we can
think of dimensions as the numbers of
labels you have to give to say where an
object is in the same way that
coordinates on a two-dimensional sheet
of paper allow you to locate any
individual point on that paper
but what about four spatial dimensions
or five
or indeed
nine
who can actually visualize what is meant
by nine spatial dimensions where else
can we go in our mind beyond up and down
and north south east and west it is hard
even to conceive of what extra spatial
dimensions
would mean there is no way to make this
perfectly intuitive but we can meet our
intuition
part of the way
one way to have a sense of this is to
imagine an insect walking on a plant
vine a vine both long and thin
an ant or any other insect can walk
along the vine either forwards or
backwards the surface of this vine
certainly has two dimensions zooming in
with a powerful microscope we would see
that the surface is made up of many
cells
stretching off in all directions
but the insect small though it is is
still too large to treat the vine as
having more than just one linear
direction in truth the surface of the
vine has two dimensions but to a big
enough insect there is effectively only
a single dimension as for the ant
so perhaps
for us
if extra dimensions are small enough we
and all our technology are simply too
big and too clunky to resolve them the
fundamental strings of string theory
would be small enough to make use of
them but without tools to resolve
structure at sufficiently small
distances we cannot sense that they are
present
imagine trying to build an intricate
lego model but while wearing boxing
gloves any structure on these distances
is simply inaccessible
but
could there still be phenomena like the
bottom on the chair where extra
dimensions could manifest their effects
even if we cannot discern their full
structure
yes
particles
physicists unable to resolve the full
structure of extra dimensions are only
sensitive to gross features it is not
there can be no information but the
information is limited a bit like trying
to describe one's daily life using a
vocabulary limited to 100 words
we could say something but think how
much would be left out
if we blur the ability to perceive extra
dimensions
then just before reaching nothing at all
the last thing we would be left with
would be particles
this is a statement of the mathematics
and it also follows from the mathematics
that the number type and interaction of
these particles would reflect the
geometry and topology of the extra
dimensions and although there may be
exceptions it is generally true that the
more complex the topology of the extra
dimensions the larger the number of such
particles that would survive
these particles would be the minimal
quantum excitation of the extra
dimensional geometry in theories of
extra dimensions they are to the extra
dimensions a bit like what the photon is
to light and electromagnetism
the minimal quantum lump that is left
and so these particles would be legacies
of a higher dimensional theory of
gravity when viewed from a lower
dimension
and so
this
leaves us with questions
what are these legacy particles if they
exist and are generic features of
theories with extra dimensions
surely we should be able to detect them
to begin with let's focus on the most
interesting and most generic type of
such particles
a modulus
modulus particles in their plural moduli
originate from describing the size and
shape of extra dimensions why then could
we not just try and observe moduli by
making them in particle colliders such
as the cern large hadron collider why
not just smash particles together at
high enough energy in order to make
moduli and thereby discover them this
after all is a long established approach
for making and discovering new particles
the problem with this approach lies in
the origin of moduli from
extra-dimensional modes of the graviton
such moduli behave like gravity and
gravity is by far intrinsically the
weakest of all the forces gravity is
such an incredibly weak force that when
you put your little finger inside a
keyring and lift up the ring in its keys
you are able to pull the ring up against
the gravitational pull of the entire
earth
this shows just how extraordinarily weak
the interactions of the gravitational
force are compared to any of the
electrostatic effects used by our bodies
and muscles the gravitational force is
therefore far far too weak to be probed
directly at any particle collider
particles whose interactions are
gravitational could never be produced
even by a collider running at full
intensity from the time of stonehenge to
now
their interactions are much weaker even
than neutrinos which famously can pass
through the entire earth without
interacting with any of the matter on
the way
so
what can we do
perhaps extra dimensions and moduli may
exist
but perhaps we can never observe them if
a collider can never make such particles
or reach the energies required to
resolve extra dimensions would they
always exist as some form of
inaccessible other shadow world which we
could never actually detect
but it is not yet time to indulge our
worst fears
it is true that interacting so weakly
moduli would be very hard to make in the
first place however this has a positive
counterpart
once they have been made moduli would
also live
for a long time
the weaker the interactions the harder
it is for a particle to decay
particles which interact via the strong
force are easily made but they typically
decay in a lifetime much less than a
billionth of a billionth of a second
whereas equivalent particles whose only
interactions are at gravitational
strength could have lifetimes measured
in years
but still to make them we would need
extreme conditions
and the most extreme conditions in the
history of the universe occurred
in its first moments
[Music]
in the beginning it is believed if not
known for an absolute certainty that the
universe underwent a period of
cosmological inflation its size grew
both rapidly and exponentially in an
extremely short period of time it is
hard to overstate the speed of this
growth indeed in the inflationary epoch
alone the universe is believed to have
doubled its size approximately 80 times
within a time period shorter than it
would take a light to cross from one end
of an atomic nucleus to another a length
corresponding to the size of that atomic
nucleus would have grown to a size far
larger than that of the earth
at the end of this inflationary epoch
the enormous energies present in the
universe were transferred away from the
energy of the inflation
into particles both making them and
flooding them with energy at the
immediate end of inflation the result is
an enormously energetic soup with
potentially many different types of
particles and these energies present
during inflation are associated with
space
and geometry itself in einstein's theory
of relativity geometry and gravity are
almost one and the same
and moduli are the particle excitations
of geometry or at least of the geometry
of the extra dimensions
and so if moduli do exist when inflation
ends and the inflationary energy is
transferred to particles it would be
natural for at least some of this
inflationary energy to be transferred to
the moduli
these share in the post-inflationary
bounty they are made they exist and they
would form some part of the male strum
of particles in which the energy of the
universe is deposited straight at the
end of the inflationary epoch
and it is here that the long long
lifetimes of the moduli
matter
moduli would live much longer than other
particles and so if this scenario is
true they would in time come to dominate
the energy density of the universe
eventually if only for a moment almost
all of the energy in the universe would
be in the form
of moduli
you can think of this a bit like a
hammer striking a great bell when first
struck the bell rings with the rich deep
sound that comes from the many harmonics
and overtones present in the bell
resonating at once
but as time goes on the higher harmonics
decay and can no longer be heard
several seconds after the original
strike the notes that remain are the
longest lasting harmonics
in the same way in the early universe
the particles that live the longest are
those that are left when all else has
decayed estimates predict that less than
a yoctosecond after the big bang most
particles would have decayed but that
moduli would last for nearly a full
microsecond
a relative eternity
[Music]
by itself this might not seem so
significant energy is conserved when
particles decay their mass energy does
not simply disappear but instead gets
converted to other forms of energy in
particular relativistic particles such
as photons the quantized version of
light
but as our new universe expands energy
in the form of relativistic waves such
as photons dissipates
rapidly the reason for this is something
called the doppler effect this effect
refers to how the pitch or frequency of
waves change depending on whether the
source of the wave is moving towards us
or away from us
it is most familiar to us from ambulance
sirens although the siren itself
operates at the same intrinsic note when
the ambulance is driving towards us we
hear the note at a higher pitch and when
the ambulance is driving away from us we
hear the note at a lower pitch
[Music]
to an observer located at some point in
an expanding universe the expansion is
like having everything move away from
you a continual growth in space itself
means that every other point in the
universe is
all the time constantly moving further
away
in these circumstances all forms of
relativistic wave energy feel the
doppler effect
as the universe is stretched the
wavelengths too are stretched and so the
frequencies the inverse of wavelength
all decrease
for light waves that is photons the
energy of the photon is directly
proportional to its frequency
as the universe expands the frequency
decreases
and the energy decreases
but for moduli the same would not be
true modulai would be heavy and their
energy associated to their mass and not
to their movement the mass energy of a
modulus would all be concentrated in the
particle itself rather than its motion
these heavy particles would not be
relativistic and would simply remain
where they are until they decay
while the universe expands they stay
right where they started maintaining all
their mass energy until the point at
which they eventually decay
meanwhile all the other particles who
have their mass energy associated to
their motion in the form of relativistic
particle waves have all this energy
dissipated away to the doppler effect
and so if moduli do exist it is likely
that the universe went through a
comparatively long phase just after
inflation where its energy was
dominantly in the form of the mass of
moduli particles
for almost a microsecond right at the
very start of the universe
the moduli had their day
almost all of the energy of the universe
in the form of quantum excitations
of extra
dimensions
were this to be true such an epoch would
change detecting moduli from the outer
realms of possibility into a more
conventional hard physics problem
how could we detect evidence for this
microsecond of moduli dominance
the answer could lie in their eventual
decay even though their gravitational
strength interactions give them longer
lives than other particles moduli do
eventually decay their mass energy
draining away into relativistic standard
model particles the hot big bang of the
early universe and also
potentially
non-standard model particles
one such example of such non-standard
model particles believed but not known
to exist
are axions if a modulus particle were to
decay to two axions they would each
receive half the mass energy of the
modulus and then proceed through space
at close to the speed of light axions
are light effectively massless and also
interact very weakly though not
predicted to be quite as weakly
interacting as modulai their
interactions are weak enough that any
axions produced this way in the early
universe would free stream from then to
now
decays of moduli could therefore have
produced a permanent cosmic background
of relativistic axions streaming through
the universe
this would be very hard to detect one
analogous weakly interacting
universe-wide particle bath is the
cosmic neutrino background which despite
there being an estimated 300 or more of
in every cubic centimeter scientists
across the globe are still struggling to
detect one or two of each year across
multiple experiments
within large magnetic fields axions
would have a chance a small chance by
the chance of converting into photons
such a universal cosmic background of
axions originating from the physics of
moduli the quantum excitations of extra
dimensions may then in principle be
detected by converting the axions into
photons within magnetic
fields
careful observations with better and
larger telescopes looking at what is
apparently nothing through magnetic
fields may in the future possibly give
evidence that the early universe was
once filled with moduli
the quantum excitations of extra
dimensions
answers
may not forever be out of reach
and so
just as einstein's theory of gravity is
barely a hundred years old the prospect
that it actually originates in more than
four dimensions is almost exactly a
hundred years old
all these decades later the idea remains
tantalizing
but still
theoretical perhaps extra dimensions
really do exist and the only reason we
are not able to perceive them is that we
are too large and clunky to appreciate
they are there trying in vain to count
sand grains while wearing boxing gloves
were they to exist they would be
everywhere present at every single point
in space and time beautifully wrapped up
miniature geometry awaiting the right
microscope to discern their beauty
and their physics
and perhaps someday somehow we may know
for certain whether or not they are out
there
and whether space itself
is much larger richer
and stranger
than we ever dreamed
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]